hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
key features of immune cells during sars
cov2 infection
i'm jennifer woods of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
of the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker sarah
debiasi
assistant professor general pathology
and immunology
school of medicine university of madana
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
sarah you may now begin your
presentation
good morning and thank you for the nice
introduction today we talk about the key
features of
immune cells during sar cov2 infection
but before starting i would like to
acknowledge people
who donate money to perform this
research
in this very difficult period so i would
like to thank
glam glass san felice
and all many people who were helping us
with their precious donation
and of course i would just want to tag
my my colleagues then during this period
help me in doing this research
and of course i would like to thank all
the clinicians that cure the people
in going to infectious disease clinics
department of anastasia and intensive
care
respiratory disease unit department of
laboratory medicine and pathology and
department of surgery
so this is the outline of the talk so i
would like to start with the
introduction
i would like to tell you something about
t cells
about cytokines term abide b lymphocytes
and immunophenotype of b lymphocyte in
surgery of e2 infection
and i would like to focus on innate
immunity
talking about monocyte monocytes and in
particular immunometabolic paralysis of
immune monocytes
and i would like to conclude my talk
so the precise mechanisms triggering the
pathogenesis is still
poorly known but two different and often
concomitant and interlinked features
have been
observed first of all the abnormal
production and utilization of
a variety of molecule of innate immunity
and second the massive activation of
cells belonging to the naked and of
adaptive immune system
and in several patients nonetheless the
immune inflammation
is really high the inflammation is not
able to clear infection
as a normal immune response leading to
several damages to the lungs
and this is our experience so the first
patient was admitted in modern
university hospital in february 36
26 2020 we collected blood coming from
the the consecutive admitted infectious
disease clinics in
the 20 21 patient with the simpsons
of include sore throat fever called this
knee
and chest pain at the mission celsiuov2
was detected in nasopharyngeal swap
specimen by real-time reverse
transcriptase pcr and in all of them
pneumonia was subsequently confirmed by
x-rays
all the patients were lymphopanic so the
lymphocyte count was really
low if compared to normal values and the
median was
more or less 100 1000
we wanted to investigate the t-cell
phenotype
in covid19 patient so we perform
a really high parameter t cell
immunophenotype and we perform
clustering analysis and
thanks to this method we were able to
identify all the spectrum
of all different subpopulation of this
cell
starting from naive going through
transitional effect transition
decels and memory now activated naive
central memory central memory recently
activated transitional memory and the
factor memory
and we were also able to identify
different subpopulation of t-rex
but what we find out is that in copic
patient
were a higher percentage of a naivety
rate a higher percentage of a factor
memory
expect expressing pd-1 a factor in
a higher a level of central memory t-reg
as well as
activated central memory t-cells we
confirmed this data
by doing manual gating as we were able
also to calculate
the number of these difference of
population
so if we didn't see any differences in
the macro population of these cells such
as a factor memory
and the transitional effect of memory t
says we were able to find differences
in the absolute number of cd40 cells
all the subpopulation was lower
if compared to a healthy subject in
particular
and a higher if compared with the
activated
factor memory t cell or a t cell
expressed in
cd 57 which is a marker of senescence
fpd1 which is a marker of
activation we were also able to
characterize
t cells in carbon 19 patients so we were
able to characterize this as in term of
the th1 th2 and th17
by analyzing the expression of cd 161
ccr7 cxcr4 and ccr4 and cxscr3 together
with tibet
and what we find out is that we find
higher level of
these cell expressing ccr4 higher level
of t-cell expressing cxcr
cr4 and higher level of
a lower level of t-cell expressing
ccr6
we performed the same on about the cd80c
cells so on cd87 we perform the same
immune
phenotype and thanks to uh flowsome were
able to
uh clusterize difference of population t
cell
covering the old spectrum properties as
a population
going from naive uh arriving to the
terminal effect or a phantom memory
expressing a scdf57 and cv
38 positive receptor
what we find out is that all the
activation
and all the activation and the
exhaustion marker were higher
in patient with the carving 19 if
compared to healthy donor
and again we confirmed this data by
doing
manual manual gaiting and if we didn't
see any different
and if we confirmed the data regarding
the percentage of the population of this
cell we were also able to
calculate absolute number and we saw and
we see that the
copy 19 patient were characterized by
lower level
of silly a lower level of cda lower
level of naivety cell
and lower level of and higher level
of activation activated t cells such as
those expressing
hladr and cd38
we were also able to characterize cd80
cell in term of th1 th2 and th17 by
using the same panel
and also here we find that the copic
patient were characterized by higher
level of cxcr4
higher level of ccrc scr4 positive
higher level of gathering cells and
higher and lower level of tibet
moreover we find more this very
interesting the fact that
this kind of cells so the one expressing
cd 161
and the ccr6 positive
uh which among the cd8 we can resemble
the mic the mucosal associated in
variantly cell population
are lower in the peripheral blood of
covenanting patients if compared to
healthy donor
and these can suggest as this kind of
cell are able to migrate
into the lungs and
produce cytokines in the lung sustaining
inflammation
we were also labored able to
characterize this kind of the
all the t-cell spectrum with the
proliferation index
then so we can see here that for example
among cd4 and among c8 the terminal
factor that the terminal factor
population is able to
er is characterized by a lower index a
lower proliferation index
among cd4 and cd8 and the higher
percentage of
divided cell are regarding cd80 cells so
maybe we can maybe we can we can explain
the fact that
the cells are characterized by higher
level of cd
57 and pd1 because they are for they
have
they have proliferated more we were also
able to qualize this
characterize this cell from a
bioenergetic point of view
so we perform the oxygen we measure the
oxygen consumption rate and the
extracellular acidification rate
among cd4 and cd8 and we didn't see any
differences between
and control and healthy donald
and this is a slide regarding the
cytokine store
so here you can see a lot of cytokines
produced by different
kind of population of t cells as well as
innate immunity cells and what we can
see here
is that the covet patients are
characterized by higher level
of cytokines pro-inflammatory cytokines
and
anti-inflammatory cytokines suggesting
that
this kind of covet patient were
characterized by
a higher level of production of these
cytokines but this kind of production
was not
regulated because we found higher level
of pro and anti-inflammatory cytokines
for example we found higher level of i8
produced by monocyte higher level of
iodine that can be produced by t
regulatory cell and th2 cells
and higher level of galactin1 and
galactin 3 and galactic 9
which are molecules produced by
monocytes and if
galactin1 is a proresolving inflammation
molecules galatine iii and galactin9
and are inflammatory are inflammatory
molecules
moreover we found higher level of tnf
alpha and higher level of interferon
gana as well as
isle alpha and i1 beta
and of course i'll iron level of i6
among a copic patient we were also able
but we wanted to see also which kind of
cytokines was
was able to produce uh t-cells
sub-population so we performed this
uh flow cytometry panel to evaluate
the expression of cells expressed
producing tnf alpha interferon gamma
il17 il2 and cd granzyme b
and cd 107a and we find out
that covet patient were characterized as
well in cd4
and as well and in cd8 with a higher
percentage of cell producing
terraform gamma tnf alpha i 17
cd 107 a in
in cd4 and in cd8
positivity cells moreover we were able
also to cult to
quantify the polyfunctional response of
these cells after in vitro stimulation
and we see here that the cavity patient
were drives by higher level of
poly functional cells among cd4 and
particularly were characterized by
higher level of il2
and il17 i17 production
so with this first part of the talk we
can state that sarcob2 creates a
dramatically confused immune response
indeed in having 19 patients with
premonia we have found the presence of
increased missile exhaustion activating
and activation and senescence
altered differentiation of different
t-cell sub-types
high plasma level of a variety of
cytokines
from those with pro-inflammatory action
to those that are able to inhibit the
immune response or that are
related to th1 th2 and th17 phenotype
and we found a massive in vitro
production of several cytokines with the
potential skewing
of activated cells towards ph 17
phenotype
in the meanwhile we were also able to
characterize b
cell phenotype and what we find out is
that
doing a poly polychromatic flow
cytometry planet investigating the
spectrum of all b-cells
we find out that plasma blast increase
in
carbon-19 patient so with the same
methods
so we're using an unsupervised method we
were able to
investigate the spectrum of all b cells
and in particular we found that all
covariate patients were the covered
patients were characterized by
higher level of different
subpopulation of b cells such as
transitional
memory igm only surface b cell
memory and switch igm negative plasma
blast
and we were also able to characterize a
population of
an unsweet cd44 24 positive b
cells characterized by the expression of
cd 2024 and the lack of expression of
cd21 resembling a population of
senescent b cells we perform also pca
so principle component analysis to
investigate
which kind of uh variation uh was
uh which kind of variation was affected
more affected more the carbon 19
patients and what we find out here is
that
for example patients with the higher
level of plasma blast and higher level
of naivety cell and higher level of
memory as which as which cell were were
able to be discharged
from the hospital if compared to those
who had
who were characterized by higher level
of the dimer higher level of software
score
higher level of crp that
were death so the main findings
regarding the b
cell was that the global alteration in
db cell
compartment that underlined the immune
system far to make up lymphopenia with
the increase in traditional b cell and
plasmoblast
memory with cells that are supposed to
remain stable or slightly increase
from 20 to from 20 to 80 years
in our patient were significantly lower
than those
of control who were younger the
increased presence of plasma blasts
in patients suggests that the
involvement of innate b
cells in production of antibodies along
with the findings that
in few cases igg but not igm
were present in the plasma of recently
infected patients
and through pca we could identify the
factors that are important in moving the
balance towards discharge
or death of the patient and the will of
opportunity represents the moment in
which a therapy like
the one that blocks is expected can be
used
and last i would like to talk about
monocyte compartments one
of uh copy 19 patient inflammation is
triggered and regulated by cell like
monocytes who are the second
protagonist or the second population who
acts in during inflammation this kind of
cell
are mhc class 2 molecules and they can
be distinguished into three different
subsets
classical monocytes intermediate
monocytes and non-classical monocytes
all of them characterized by different
expression of cd14
and cd16
all of these population rely on both
oxygen phosphorylation and glycolysis
for atp
production but no one investigated how
sarcoid infection could impact monocyte
metabolism
and function we did that and we find out
that
monocytes of copic patient were
characterized by a lower
oxygen consumption rate a lower atp link
a lower maximal respiratory capacity a
lower proton leak
and the lower oxidative oxidative bursts
and
a lower basal eclair showing that this
kind of monocytes were metabolically
exhausted and in particular calculating
the area under the cure we were able to
see
uh the ability to maintain the maximal
respiration and the
ability to maintain the maximal
oscillative burst
and this kind of maximal respiration and
oxidative birth was lower
where in a patient within a copied
patient if compared to healthy subject
given the fact that mitochondria is the
powerhouse of this
are the powerhouse of the cells and the
oxidative phosphorylation
happen in mitochondria we would like to
have a look at
mitochondria by doing a transmission
electron microscopy images
and what we find out is that
mitochondria from covered patient worker
were
different in terms of uh dimension
they were characterized by a higher
heterogeneity
heterogeneity in shape and in particular
even if
we found that the the membrane of
mitochondria was
uh was fine was okay the the inside part
the inside part
display a higher degree of uh swelling
and in particular we found changes in
the aspect ratio and in particular
in the in the roughness we wanted to
characterize mitochondria by analyzing
the mitochondria master by using
mitotrakal green and mitochondria
membrane potential by using jc1 and what
we find out is that
mitochondrial mass was higher in
patients with
inpatient with carbon 19 covenant
inpatient
and the mitochondria membrane potential
they depolarized the percentage of the
polarized mitochondria was higher in a
copied name team patient
if compared to healthy subject
we wanted to investigate also the
landscape of monocyte phenotype in
carbon and impatient
and we follow the same approach we did
for the other two studies and so we
wanted we were able to identify
classical monocyte
intermediate monocyte expressing ccr2
and intermediate monocyte
not expressed in ccr2 and not classical
monocyte
and what we find out is that we found
that copied patients were characterized
by higher level of
intermediate ccr2 expressing t cells
higher level of intermediate not
expressing ccr to
a lower level of classical and the
similar level of
a non-classical and non-classical
non-classical monocytes
we wanted to confirm also this by doing
manual gating so we were able to
identify
cd14 on the basis of the expression of
cd14 and ct16
three different uh subpopulation of
monocytes so the classical express
in cd 14 and lower level of cb16
the intermediate expressing higher level
of cd14 and higher level of
cv16 and the non-classical monocyte the
one
expressed in low level of cd14 and
higher level of cd16
and in this population we wanted to
analyze exhaustion markers such as pdl1
and thin3
we confirmed by manual gating that
copied patients were characterized by
lower level of classical monocyte higher
level
of intermediate monocyte and unchanged
level of non-classical monocytes
and regarding the the expression level
of
pd-1 and pdl-1 so exercise the
exhaustion marker
we found that this marker was higher in
patient incognitive patient if compared
to healthy donors in all the different
population
of of monocytes so this kind of cells
can be were metabolically exhausted but
also express also higher level of
exhaustion markers such as pd-1 and
pdl-1
given the ex given the metabolic
exhaustion we wanted to investigate also
the in vitro cytokine production by
monocyte in copper 19 patients so we
stimulated monocytes with pmanomycin
and we analyzed the expression of tn
alpha and
interferon gamma and what we find out is
that even if
patients were characterized by a
metabolically exhaustive monocyte
the cytokine production was unchanged
after
in vitro stimulation so this cell were
still able to produce
cytokine as well as healthy subject
but we wanted to investigate also plasma
level
of cytokines and chemokines involved in
monocytes regulation
and also here we found that the covet
patient copy 19 patients were
characterized by higher level
of pro-inflammatory cytokines such as
is60 nf
interferon gamma il-18 pdl1
and higher level also of granular
gm csf opn and the cx
cl 10. and even the fact that we found
higher level of
gmcsf in the plasma of covet patient
we wanted also to investigate the
presence of immature monocytes in
covalent impatient peripheral blood
and by doing a flow cytometric panel
based on the expression
of hladr cd14 and cd13 we were able to
identify and
uh cdm 64. we were able to identify
immature monocytes and matrimonies so
imagine monocyte
were not expressing cd13 and cd14
and cd 60 64
and major monocytes were those
expressing
all of these three markers and we find
out that
in the peripheral blood of uh
covenanting patient
there are a higher percentage of
immature
monocytes if compared to healthy subject
so if we want to conclude we found that
unaltered by energetics and
mitochondrial
expansion of monocyte impatient with
carbon 19 pneumonia and this kind of
ultraviolets and mitochondria
dysfunction resemble the one
that someone found in sepsis
in which monocytes are characterized by
immuno-metabolic paralysis
so here we find that this we find
dysfunctional monocytes with decreased
respiratory bursts that increase
expression of inhibitory checkpoints
abnormal mitochondria with low membrane
potential
and decrease oxfords and unchange
cytokine production
with a completely different landscape of
monocyte
in cure including the presence of
immature monocytes among peripheral
blood of coping 19 patients
so if you want to wrap up the immune
system of cognitive
patient is disregulating and it is
characterized by
mark t cell activation senescence
exhaustion
and skewing toward th17 expansion of
plasma blast and loss of memory b cells
in peripheral blood
and metabolic exhaustive monocytes and
different distribution of monocytes
so population and having said that i
would like to tell you to wear the mask
and thank you for your attention
thank you sarah for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
today okay let's get started our first
question
is could it be concluded that there is
an immunological consensus signature
among all coven 19 patients
oh thank you very much for this question
because this question gives me the
opportunity to wrap up what is
what has been found in the last month in
covet 19 research
so first of all i would like to start
with the cytokine storm
because we found the plasma of the
patient a lot of pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory cytokines so it seems
that
the immune system of the coveted
patients
is kind of like to react in a desperate
attempt to
respond to viral infection in a very
unorganized way
for instance we found high level of
pro-inflammatory cytokines such as
galactin1
il-6 il-8 10f alpha but
also higher level of anti-inflammatory
cytokines such as the il-4
il-10 tgf beta and cmcsf
so this kind of uh
this kind of concentration reflect at
this point attempt of the immune system
to
answer to this kind of infection even if
the pro-inflammatory status is anyway
predominant in the in
in the plasma level of this patient
second of all i would like to
uh to say to underline that we found
that this regulation in monocytes
because we found a higher
level of pro-inflammatory cytokines
produced by
monocytes and the presence of immature
monocytes in blood
due pro due to probably high level of
gmcsf
and monocytes are characterized by
dysfunctional metabolism in terms of
respiration and glycolysis mitochondria
are depolarized bigger but characterized
by morphological swelling so
we didn't find any kind of changes in
term of cytokine production
after pma unomizing third we found this
regulation in t
cells so we found higher level of
activation of t
cells in terms of expression of cp38
hladr expression of pd1 and cd57
and we found that this kind of cell were
able to proliferate more
and in particular in the effector
compartment that could explain the
higher level of
cd57 moreover we found higher level of
th1 cytokine and th1 tth17 cytokine
produced by both cd4 and cd8
and fourth we found this regulation in
all b cell compartment b cell are very
important for the production of
antibodies and we found very higher
percentages of plasma blasts the
decrease of
naive b cells compartment even if the
patient were
older than the healthy subject an
increase
of transitional b cell and a decrease of
memory switch and as which
we cells and we did not found changes in
b-cell proliferation so overall we found
a lot of this regulation in the immune
system
of uh calvin 19 patients
okay thank you sarah we have another
question
what are the weakest points of viral
infection progression that can become
therapeutically relevant
with intervention on the immune response
oh this is a very interesting question
because i
think that the crucial point is the
immune response
given by the innate immune response
because of course is the first one
that is able to produce cytokines in for
instance
neutrophils and monomonocytes are able
to migrate into the inflamed tissue and
are
able to produce pro-inflammatory
cytokines and give origin to this kind
of so-called cytokine storms
so i think that calming the cytokine
storms
through the immune modulation is one of
the current managements of covid19
patient by using for example totalizumab
that is able to block i6 receptor or by
using corticosteroids
and then there is another point that are
the adaptive immune response that is
able to mount
the um immune response and this kind of
cells are able to continue
to produce inflammatory cytokines and
recruits
other system other immune players in in
in the size of infection
so i think that the new modulation is
the core the the best current management
that
we apply by now
thank you sarah i have another question
the increase in the expression of pdl1
on monocytes and the increase of
intermediate monocytes in covid19
patients is very interesting
what was the gating strategy for
identifying pdl1-positive cells
and cd16 positive cells oh thank you for
the question because i have the chance
to clear
our type of analysis so we perform two
kinds of
we perform a ten colors panel flow
cytometry
uh to analyze the expression of
different markers in different
population of monocytes we analyze the
expression of c
cr2 pd1 pdl one fin three and cd38 and
cxcr3
and we applied two different methods to
perform this kind of
analysis so the first one was the
unsupervised analysis so
for the unsupervised analysis we use
flowsome clustering and then
flossom was run and we were
very careful with with the cofactor and
with everything that could be care in
the analysis and then we confirmed this
kind of analysis with an
manual gating strategy based on the
fluorescence venus one control
so we establish the positivity and the
negativity for
all the markers by using this kind of
control so
in our panel uh hdr was were present so
we selected hdr
positive and dim and cd 15 positive and
then in this population we selected the
population expressed in cd14
and cd16 and in this population we
analyze the expression of different
markers such as
also a pdl one we tried different
antibodies for pdl one because we had
some kind of issue with the stainings
and with the specificity of the antibody
and at the end we chose a clone
from thermo fisher which is the mah1 by
thermal
and we're happy with that and we were
able to analyze
the percentage of cell expressing this
marker and also
the meaning of the medium fluorescence
intensity
thank you we have another question yes
are any of these patients treated with
any antiviral or anti-immune drugs
no the patient included in this kind of
studies so studies in visa t
cells b cells and monocyte were all
patients without any kind of treatment
because we selected
patients at time zero so we had the
blood before they started any kind of
uh therapy patients here in modena are
follow are
treated with different therapies such as
tochilizumab or
corticosteroids but we were able to
take the blood before the administration
offered this drug so
in this kind of data we show only what
happened in with carbon infection
without
any kind of interference by drugs
okay thank you next question
any differences in immune profile in
like older patients versus younger
patients
oh we are thank you for this question we
are still analyzing data
obtained with different methods we are
still analyzing this kind of patient
with this kind of data and we were able
to analyze
covered over 70 and
copied the copy infected person under 60
and we found some kind of differences in
the main subpopulation of t
cells and mesa population of b cells
but of course we are still analyzing
these kind of patients so i cannot say
more because i have to validate
everything but yes there is there are
differences on the basis of the age
there are differences in terms of
differential population
for example of t cells mainly they are
the domain that
we can observe during the natural course
of
life so a decrease of an iot cell and an
increase of the factor memory population
but yes we can see a difference okay
thank you um we have one more question
what is the predominant finding in
covid19 immunosuppression or
immunoactivation this is this is very
this is a very interesting question
i think that this kind of question i can
ask
thinking as example uh
sepsis uh sepsis disease because in
substitutes
we have uh two kind of phases so the
immune
they need the hyper reactive phase and
the hyporeactive phase that is followed
by the
hyperactive phase and i think that in
covingtin it is uh
something i mean can happen something
very similar
because at the beginning we have this
kind of
cytokine storm so we can speculate that
this kind of immune system
is very very triggered by the infection
and at some point there are some kind of
dysregulation and exhaustion that take
place because of course
this cell expressed higher level of pd1
and cd57 so
i think that on the basis of when we
take the blood and in which kind of
part of the disease maybe we can talk
about immunoactivation
on or immune deregulation but i think
that
there is some kind of similarities with
the sepsis
disease
okay well thank you again sarah for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye